dr
thank you what have we got today what
are we doing okay today we're going to
talk about reading numbers i don't mean
like numerology like reading the stars
or anything i mean actually seeing a
number and reading it and speaking it
and the processes that happen when
you're doing that
if we're going to talk about reading
then we probably should think about
words quickly because we know a whole
lot about how we read words there are
two different processes in the brain
when we read words we can either read
words that we're familiar with which are
legal words and those are ones that we
have like a long-term memory
representation of so words that you can
find in a dictionary
um cat lamppost elephant tutu
that's a really interesting mental image
i've just got there i don't know where
that came from those are just four of
the many words that are available to you
and we know that people can read those
because they see it and they recognize
the kind of shape of it and then they
produce the noise they produce the
phonological form of that word however
when you're reading something that's a
non-word
like
blurgle merge you're actually doing
something very different because you
can't recognize it and then produce it
you're actually looking at it letter by
letter so we know that there are two
different routes that you can take when
reading words and non-words now if we
think about it there is actually an
equivalent to this with numbers
now your reaction to me saying that is
what's a non-number because there's no
such thing as a dictionary of numbers
there are infinitely many numbers i've
checked it on wikipedia if you go to the
list of numbers wikipedia article it
will tell you that it is an incomplete
list so there are actually i've double
checked an infinite number of numbers if
you if we're going to allow things like
blurgle marge probably an infinite
number of words blurgle marge is a
non-word so that falls outside of the
scope there is no numerical equivalent
to blurgill marge
so what are we actually looking at
the equivalent
is whether or not the numbers that
you're reading
are familiar or meaningful to you
or whether or not they're unfamiliar or
meaningless to you the thing that
happens in your brain when you read a
number that you're familiar with is
different to what happens when you read
a number that you are unfamiliar with
okay the same as with the words exactly
exactly there are multiple different
routes that you can choose to read a
number so if you ask me how you define a
familiar number the answer is poorly
it's super subjective there are numbers
that are familiar to me that will mean
absolutely nothing to you and vice versa
there are
a massive set of numbers that
culturally we all find familiar so for
example the the year 2015 that's
familiar to all of us um but if i was to
pick the number
one eight zero four
that probably doesn't mean much to you
no that's because it's my birthday how
dare you not know where my birthday is
oh what is in the 18th exactly so that
number however is very familiar to
myself i think the number 1066 is
probably a familiar number to most
people however having had that
assumption very confidently around a lot
of people i realized that some people's
knowledge of history is not exactly as
good as you might imagine i guess
numbers that are like titles or films
and things like that exactly yes lower
numbers are better for this i have done
some research on this and i basically
made this survey and got people to just
type in a load of numbers they liked and
then assess whether or not they thought
they were familiar or random the
distribution was the case that a lot of
the lower numbers were very much more
familiar to people and then as you went
up in magnitude the frequency of
familiar numbers that you got decreased
however there were like nice peaks you
get peaks for numbers that look like
years so i wanted to know when when the
kind of future would end i think i did
this a couple of years ago so 2013 was a
familiar number to people
14 15 16 was but 2017 people decided was
not familiar to them so it seems yes
four years that's that's the end of the
future and people don't care about it
after after that it appears obviously
now you're sitting there thinking well
2017 is highly familiar to me that's
because that's two years away and you're
in the future now so there are other
things
90210 is a familiar thing to people and
that's interesting in itself because it
began as a zip code but it probably
doesn't mean a zip code to most people
it probably means the tv program there's
a whole load of reasons for numbers to
be familiar to us okay okay okay let's
let's let's let's explore this so i said
there were multiple different routes i'm
going to give us a start number so this
is the number that we are going to be
reading the most basic thing that we can
do with it is we can take it and turn it
into its arabic numeral form
so that is when we're reading it out we
get out at the end one
nine eight nine it has no other meaning
beyond it's just a string of digits and
they don't interfere with or talk to
either either of the other digits around
it very straightforward obviously now
the next thing we can do is we can turn
it into its number word form now this is
probably going to be a bit contentious
i'm going to turn it into the word form
1989. i say contentious because i think
that when you read that number that is
probably not the first thing you go to
when you read it as a word so with the
first one you haven't done any
processing on it you've just gone digit
by digit and turned it into its
phonological form whereas with this
second way of processing it what you've
had to do is work out exactly which
digit you're reading and also the
position of that digit within the number
so this nine gets read out as nine
whereas this nine gets joined to the one
and becomes the number 19. on the
mathematical route this means we might
come up with
some mathematical facts about the number
so when you read that number you might
say i know that that number is greater
than one thousand i know that that
number is odd there's a whole load of
things you might know that number
represents an um kind of an amount of
something
it it it has a it has a meaning beyond
the first two levels that we talked
about whereas and it has constituent
parts exactly and it has it has it has
rules that it adheres to up until like
quite recently all models of number
reading have have have really just
focused on these these three levels we
call this one surface reading and this
one is a deeper semantic reading of it
what you've had to do is not just turn
that into a phonological form you've
also had to appreciate the kind of
meaning behind it and what it actually
um relates to there is an a fourth
level
and this is kind of something that we've
only recently started trying to put into
models of number reading and that fourth
level is something called an
encyclopedic lookup and this is what
happens when the number that you're
reading
has
some position in your long-term memory
that is when the number that you're
reading
means something to you
when you've come across it before in
some circumstance
so this number you may have realized
looks quite a lot like a year for
example 1989
to me the reason i've chosen it is
because that is a personal important
number to me because that is where my
sister was born that's my sister yeah
yay there is also a cultural
significance to this year at the moment
taylor swift's
incredible new album is called 1989. is
that because she was born in 1991 i
assume so is taylor swift your sister
i've chosen this method to tell everyone
that yes taylor swift is my younger
sister so there is this
more cultural and kind of shared reason
for this number to be familiar to me you
brady i know
and probably millions and millions and
millions of other people that have
caused this album to be at the number
one spot for 10 weeks running or
something like that so you get this
cultural significance taylor
there are lots of models of number
reading and they haven't really
incorporated
all of these these these levels um
together before and
the reason it's interesting
is because we can
kind of prove that these levels exist it
might like i say it might be kind of
obvious to you that you can read these
numbers like this and you're probably
not aware of you doing all of these
different things
but
people that are aware of this are
researchers who look at patients with
aphasia aphasia is a language disorder
that is often caused by a brain trauma
and by language disorder i mean it's
affects your ability to
affects your ability to read sometimes
it affects your ability to speak
but
that's all it does it doesn't affect
your understanding of what of what
you're reading or trying to say some
people
get a specific effect of aphasia on
their ability to read numbers it can
kind of
take out some of these
pathways but not all of them not all of
them which is the really really cool and
interesting thing in this paper there's
they do this case study and they look at
a man who is 43 and he suffers a brain
trauma and then he um develops aphasia
as a result of that this guy his ability
to do that digit-by-digit reading had
had been lost and so when he was shown a
number that he was unfamiliar with he
couldn't read it out loud that means
this pathway here had been taken out
this pathway here had been taken out as
well so no longer could he rely on just
sounding out numbers or producing number
words so he was very interested in
racing rally cars in particular so he
was shown this number
he said the number of cars that win it
was my first car it begins with a p
peugeot renault it's peugeot 403 no 500
504 so that's how he managed to get to
it because
504 is a brand of peugeot car that
according to this man
wins it's the car that wins and so that
shows you exactly how he managed to read
it out loud he went through this
encyclopedic stage and found this
memory representation of the number and
was able to read out loud so if you'd
shown him 505
he would never he would have had no
chance no couldn't even say it no he
wouldn't have been able to do it but he
wouldn't even be able to say oh
that's a five that's a zero and that's a
five he would read this unfamiliar
number out as the similar familiar
number if you see what i mean so if i
had shown him five by five he might have
said 504 yes exactly yeah so there was
one example the patient is french and
apparently in france the the common
thing for doctors to check your
breathing is to ask you to say the
number 33 and so that makes it a
familiar number to him and he was shown
the number
which was unfamiliar to him and he sat
and looked at it and he said 33 because
he was desperately trying to read it out
and so took this encyclopedic route and
that was the closest number that he
could find was was 33. you didn't cross
out the mathematical branch
showed him two numbers he would know
which was bigger than the other or yes
it does mean that he was able to do that
he still had the mathematical ability
and
he was still able to tell which of two
numbers were larger if he was shown
equations he could tell you whether the
equation was correct or not you read it
in a mathematical way you kind of access
this these set of facts
but you still have to read it out loud
this patient yes was able to perform
comparisons understand inequalities
but he had still lost
this branch so he couldn't read the
numbers out so he he knew that 10 plus
10 equals 20 is correct yeah but
couldn't say it couldn't say it out loud
no couldn't get to it unless for some
reason 20 was very familiar to him the
number 19 he he read initially as the oh
that's the edge of my daughter that's
the age of my daughter before finally
getting to
19. um if he yeah so if he'd have been
able to do some maths that got to 19
then yes but he would have been using
this route and not this route to say it
it's twice a day really that i have a
good chunk of spare time when i take the
dogs out for a walk and that would seem
like a great chance to catch up on say
the latest books
but reading and walking at the same time
has its pitfalls
don't worry help is at hand crack out
the phone and download an audio book
from audible.com now audible has a
staggering range of books and you can
have your choice piped into your ears
with just a few taps of your thumb
there are plenty i could recommend but
i'm not above being a bit biased so why
not look at these ones by people who
actually start in number file videos and
i'll put the titles of their books below
in the video description now if you go
to audible and you use the url
audible.com
slash number file you will make these
puppies very happy
and you'll be showing your appreciation
to audible for its support of this
number file video oh and while you're at
it there's something in it for you you
will get a free audio book the free
audiobook of your choice maybe one of
those ones i've recommended when you
sign up for a trial did you hear that a
free audio book and happy puppies what
more could you ask
check them out thanks to audible and
never walk into a tree again
i'm going to do a not equal just in case
you were still
thinking that maybe taylor might be my
sister